rocket raccoon you did that uh it took
two years to complete that project
people think you go in the studio and do
the voice for one day
like doing uh sniper and then chef and
alphabet it was hilarious
all over the place does it take two
years because they try something out
then they need you to go back and do a
different voice
it takes years because that's the
process by which they're making the
movie so
in that process because there's cgi
there's all these effects there's all
this stuff
i keep popping in how does it work do
they do they
they already filmed everything and then
i come in oh and you try to match the
the the
no no you get to do whatever you want
you it's really kind of amazing it's as
if
this conversation was filmed with you
talking to just some other person that
was responding or saying lines were
written
and then i come in and then they're
gonna physically put me in here and then
i get to react to what you're saying
keep calling me vermin tough guy you
just want to laugh at me like everyone
else
i live for the simple things like how
much this is gonna hurt
and then that can change based on my my
response to you
it's crazy so that's a huge example i
make fun of benicio del toro in
the movie rocket does and then so they
changed this whole thing and the scene
changes then you see rocket make fun of
that character which wasn't the way it
was he starts doing like a thing
beautiful blah blah blah
we're all very fascinated whitey you are
on your way man you could be
you're going to be a legend you do it
all you're funny you're serious and by
the way you were so good
i love burnt did you believe yes i
believe you're a chef
i believe you're a pregnant yeah you
look like a guy and i believe we did all
the cooking yeah
because we worked so well when you play
a chef do you watch other chefs work is
that how you learn
oh my god when you play a raccoon do you
live with raccoons so you're learning
yeah